[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to if you checked out my recent
season 8 spoiler video you'll know that
a previously covered some plot leaks in
regards to episode 5 and 6 of the show
with episode 5 just releasing we can now
confirm that roughly about 50% of what
was said in those leaks was true and
that overall as a narrative arc they
were pretty accurate just as a follow-up
on this I thought I'd put together a
list of the correct leaks as well as
what new ones have come both about
Episode six throughout this video I'll
be dropping all of the in-depth the
reveals that we have on the finale as
well as giving my thoughts on how
legitimate I think that they are this is
full spoilers ahead so if you don't want
to potentially have the ending of the
show room for yourself then I highly
suggest that you turn off now we won't
know if this is the case until we see
for ourselves to take everything with a
grain of salt as always but if you
checked out the prior video then you
know that some of them were accurate
some of them weren't so I thought I just
put everything together in one video
anyway with that out the way huge thank
you for clicking on this video I hope
you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my breakdown of the Game
of Thrones Season 8 spoilers okay so
just a quick recap so the user that
revealed the spoilers on reddit was
called Mr Freeze night King and they
were quickly banned after a lot of them
appeared to be true the main ones that
turned out to be accurate in this
episode with that Varys did end up
turning on Dany after deciding that John
would be a better leader and that he was
burned alive because of it the user also
correctly stated that Arya and the Hound
would infiltrate King's Landing whilst
an arrow set fire to the city after the
golden company surrendered in the red
keep freeze night King stated that
Cersei and Jaime met up and died
together and that area was almost
crushed under rubble whilst they stated
that the Hound rescued her and we know
this didn't happen they pretty much got
the circumstances right and had the
Hound killing the mountain but the two
facing off this episode the biggest
thing now that of course came from the
leaks was that Daenerys slowly became
the Mad Queen they use a state
and no I didn't cover this in my episode
but I probably should have looking back
so don't thumbs down the video please
they stated that Jon Snow does not agree
with the killing of soldiers that have
surrendered and this of course came up
in the episode too now going forward Mr
Freeze night King states that Jon Snow
kills Dany in the final episode and this
leak is something that I 100% agree with
they say that it comes down to a choice
between siding with his adoptive family
or his blood one and he chooses to stay
with the Starks and thus has to betray
Dany in the process
everyone is incredibly angry at her
after episode 5 including Tyrion who's
mad that she caused Jamie's death and no
it wasn't intentional he's still pretty
annoyed at the whole situation and he
throws down his hand pendant at her this
is because she's arguably worse than
Cersei and they say that Danny's death
apparently happens in the throne room of
King's Landing
with the character collapsing against
the throne as she passes away which
symbolically shows that she did
eventually make it though her anger
stopped her from sitting on it according
to the leaks
drogon is still alive at this point but
instead of killing Jon he just grabs her
body and flies away the leak says that
this is because it recognizes John is
Targaryen but I don't know if this will
definitely happen in the episode we'll
just have to see this does however
fulfil the original vision that Danny
had in season 2 of a throne room with
snow around it also in the episode Jon
sees area is a faceless one and this is
a pretty big reveal for the character
now the producers of Game of Thrones
shot multiple endings for the show so
it's a bit difficult to decipher exactly
which one is true but switching from my
recent video the creative team have
apparently settled on the ending where
Sansa becomes the queen John still heads
up back north and bran rebuilds the wall
using his magic at this point
genre nights with ghost and this is
meant to be the part where he finally
finally pets him yay been waiting for
that for so long
anyway this seems to be a more likely
ending than the bran one and we still
have the show closing with Jon
discovering a spiraling circle of bodies
that shows that the White Walkers will
be back eventually though we don't know
when I actually think that this
signifies ER there will always be a need
for a
starke on the throne to fight the White
Walkers and that they will rise up every
couple of thousand years to return to
fight the living it does leave some
questions and obviously you should still
take this all with a pinch of salt but
I'd love to hear your thoughts on these
leaks and if you think that they will
happen there's quite a lot of people
angry with how the show's been going for
the final season so of course I'd love
to see what people think of it and if
this will rectify it for them comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my full breakdown of
every episode in the season so far
including all of my fan theories which
will be linked in a playlist at the end
we've also just launched some merch on
the channel so if you want to support
videos like this and get some free
clothing out of it make sure you click
the boxes in the description it goes a
long way and a massively appreciate
everyone who picks one up this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]